ils ne construiraient jamais quelque chose comme ça
sans une porte dérobée au cas où ça
s'effondrerait jamais jamais il doit y avoir
autre chose regardez autour de vous tout le monde
regardez autour de vous qu'est-ce qu'on cherche pour moi je
ne sais pas ce que c'est parce que c'est
quelque chose oui oui George  qu'est-ce que c'est pas de
chimie c'est la porte du mythique
mais c'est la porte je sais que je sais que la porte
non non non personne n'a travaillé plus tôt en
conjonction avec ça ouais c'est
comme ci-dessus donc ci-dessous si cette phrase est
considérée comme la clé de tout  magie comme
ci-dessus donc ci-dessous donc s'ils ont sculpté un duel
au plafond il doit y avoir une porte
ouais tu es bien au fond
des catacombes il n'y a rien en dessous
c'est le sol porte un
multi jauge en cuir c'est une sortie euh  je n'y vais pas